Speaker 1: This next story is part tragedy and
it's part comedy of errors. Another Republican
official has sadly died of covid. That's the
tragic part. When people die, it's a tragedy. This
time, it's the bookkeeper for the Hillsborough
County, Florida Republican Party. His name was
Greg Prentis. He was 61 years old. He was the
accountant for the Hillsborough County GOP.
He built and maintained, maintained the local
Republican Party's campaign finance software. Last
year. He was the guy filing the monthly reports
to the FEC, the Federal Elections Commission.
He also was a big anti VAX guy. Greg
Prentis. Fear mongered against vaccines,
fear mongered against masks was totally against
other pandemic health guidelines. He attacked Dr.
Fauci, posting on Facebook that America
needs to, quote, end fascism. Well, he died.
And now nobody else has the login or the password
for the accounts needed to file these reports
with the FEC or any idea how to use them. The
Hillsborough County Republican Party is now in
quite a pickle, I guess we would say. They put out
a statement saying, quote, As a political party
committee, we file our FEC reports on a monthly
basis. For several years, we've been submitting
the reports electronically. And for over a year
we've done this with software developed by one
of our members, Greg Prentiss. Greg Software
converted data from cookbooks to supply the
information needed by the FEC. Unfortunately, Greg
passed away suddenly from covid on September 11th.
Greg did not share the software and instructions
for its use with our officers. We will have to
enter August data manually. And according to the
information we've received from our FEC analysts,
we may likely have to reenter the data from our
first seven months of 2021. We will be struggling
to get all of this entered in the proper format
by our deadline on September 20, but we will try
to do so with our best effort. This is another
bizarre example of covid crippling the Republican
Party, but quite different than what we've
become used to. Now, as another little note,
Greg Prentice's death has also opened up a whole
deluge of conspiracy theories from other local
Republican Party officials, one who called covid
a, quote, medically engineered virus and suggested
without any evidence that Greg Prentice's
death was actually a result of wrongdoing by
the hospital where he was being treated rather
than by covid itself. In other words, IT guy
rants against vaccines and against masks for over
a year, catches covid and ends up in the hospital,
dies. And the conspiracy is it wasn't covid that
killed him. It was improper. It was malpractise
essentially by the doctors, not covid itself. And
and this is, again, as we've talked about before,
this is indefeasible. The classic example is I
come to you and I say, sir, there's an invisible
elephant in the room with us right now. And
you say, OK, well, it might be invisible, but
it still has weight. So let's put a scale
down and we'll know if there's an invisible
elephant here because the elephant will step
on the scale. And then I say, well, though,
not only is it invisible, it's also a weightless,
invisible elephant. I say, OK, all right, fair.
You know what? It must still move the air around
it. So let's put down a bunch of baby powder.
And as the invisible weightless elephant moves
around because it has volume, it will still
displace the baby powder. And then I say, no, no,
no, it's invisible and weightless and it has no
volume and it doesn't. At a certain point, you
can't defeat any argument that is based on this
kind of framework, he didn't really die of covid,
he died from being mistreated at the hospital.
What we'd really love to be able to see is these
people lose because they don't offer policy that
makes any sense and because they run terrible
elections, not because they're unvaccinated and
dying of covid. That would be my preference. And
imagine, by the way, if the situation was reversed
and you had Democrats saying, hey, you know
what? We had one person with the password
to the accounting software, they died. So now
we're going to be late on filing with the FEC,
the MAGGA people or the CU people or whoever.
They would be saying the Clintons had him killed,
the Clintons had him killed because the FEC
documents were going to expose that they were
fill in the blanks, absconding with money,
whatever the embezzling, whatever the case may be.
Crazy situation. You've got to share that username
and password. We'll have more coverage of this and
similar stories on our Instagram. Find
us on Instagram at David Pakman show.